there is a theory i'm developing with
collaborators that we're using for life
detection which is called assembly
theory it was first developed for
detecting alien life but the way we
think about it if you take something
like a molecule
or a person we would say in this theory
that they're an assembly space for a
molecule it's very easy to visualize so
you take a molecule if you break it in
half and you break it in half again and
break it in half again you can get to
elementary building blocks and then you
can take those and try to reassemble
them like imagine you have a stack of
red and blue legos and you take them
apart and then you want to find all the
ways to reassemble that original object
in assembly theory those more complex
objects have longer and longer shortest
paths for assembling them and so we talk
about the shortest path to make
something as being an intrinsic feature
of the objects and then the argument is
that if you had
if you see a complex object and it
requires too many minimal steps for the
universe to produce it then it's a
signature that you had a living process
there or something that had information
or knowledge about how to make that
specific object